[Music]
take one more and go to james in
uh bend oregon it sounds like a yoga
pose gone wrong what's up dude
how you doing we're rocking and rolling
man how are you
pretty good i am wondering um what i can
do to help my fiance
dream about the future more and
talk with me kind of about what her
dreams are
tell me more
so
um you know
we've been obviously dating for quite a
few years and we're going to be getting
married in about a year
and so you know i like to talk with her
about kind of what our future plans are
and
uh i'm the kind of guy who i've known
what i've wanted to do since i was a
little kid and you know i'm in that kind
of career path now and
she doesn't really know
what she wants to do and so she's having
a real hard time
kind of figuring out what that is and
when i try to talk with her about it she
says it kind of makes her anxious and
she doesn't want to talk about it
and
i'm kind of just wanting to know what i
can do to to help her because i don't
really get anxious like that about stuff
so i don't really understand
why it's hard for her
so
the short of it is you can't
you
she's got to choose to do that
um so
the only conversation i can have here is
with you and so i want to shift the
focus from her to you is that cool
yeah
so my first question to you would be
have you created a
safe relational context for her to dream
about something
so i'm imagining and i'm just gonna
start throwing stuff up against the wall
and you tell me if it sticks okay
okay you've known what you've wanted
since you were little
and maybe you started dating her and you
were very clear about your destination
and your dreams and where y'all you
wanted to go
and then she fell in love with you and
she liked your drive and she liked where
you wanted to go
and you've known where you want to go
and so you went to college to go where
you want to go like you see what i'm
saying and now when you look at her and
say well what do you want
however long you all have dated it's
been very clear that what
we are going to do is what he wants to
do
okay so my question and again that may
not be the case at all um what i'm
asking is have you created a relational
context
a relational environment where she feels
safe saying i don't like this
and you're not gonna fly off the handle
roll your eyes get mad be a jerk you'll
be like oh great awesome
yeah i mean i feel like i have him we
don't
you know we don't really fight we're uh
you know we always have fun and happy
and i've told her you know it's like i'm
a completely supportive of whatever you
want to do she's she's had like a couple
ideas but
you know where it was like a school
after her four-year degree and you know
completely different area of the country
than i would want to live and i told her
you know
i'm cool with that like we can do it i'm
excited if it's you know if it's what
you want to do if it's what you're
really passionate about but then none of
it you know she kind of gets into a
little bit and it doesn't it's not
really something that she really feels
super passionate about so then
she kind of doesn't want to do that and
then so she doesn't
and i've tried to you know
like i said i've tried to be as
supportive as i can because i totally am
cool with doing
you know kind of whatever it is because
with my kind of career path i can kind
of go anywhere okay cool
all right so so that so you're not a
jerk that's what i was i was circling up
so that's not you okay you're an open
guy you're super cool to talk to
um so here's the second piece
if in the next six months she doesn't
open up to you
she continues to just be quiet and just
kind of do life the way she wants to do
life and let you lead the way
um
are you thinking about breaking up with
her
no
so you're into this thing
yeah okay
here's where that's important um
i always want to find out where
somebody's values are okay versus this
would be cool if
i would really like it if
the value is i have to
like i need a partner who will
um spar with me intellectually who will
fight for what they want and i'll fight
for what i want and together we'll build
something magical right
um if that's something you have to have
and if you're not gonna have it you're
gonna end up getting bored in your
marriage and you're gonna end up seeking
that that connection somewhere else
then go ahead and break up
okay
the other side of it is if you say no
that's just who she is i just wish she
would be more open
then i think you approach that
conversation with
i'm really interested in
you and i building something together
and right now i'm the only person
putting blueprints down on the table
and i feel like you're 50 of this and
i'm i'm missing your half of my heart
and over the next x number for whatever
reason i feel comfortable talking about
that's cool
um she may have been rejected a lot as a
kid she may have been told that her
ideas and opinions don't matter and
she's stupid who knows what her
childhood looks like you would know that
way more than i would
all that to say is what you're gonna
have to do over time is teach her
that her voice matters
okay teach her that her opinion has
weight
and that you not only you'll just do it
but that you value it
and that she's got wisdom to share in
the how in your house right and the
whole idea is we're creating something
together it's less what do you want to
do
and who do we want to become together
okay see what i'm saying
yeah that sounds super cheesy
like oh okay
really it's
as simple as
hey i went through instagram or
pinterest and i have five houses that i
think are awesome
this week on our date i want you before
our date i want you to pick five of your
favorite houses
imaginary houses that if we had 10
million we could live in and i wanted to
learn more about why you think these are
beautiful houses
okay okay there's no pressure there
right or
what
celebrity is the most like man and woman
what's the most attractive celebrity and
why
like
you're taking it off like how would you
like me to do my hair well suddenly
there's a ton of pressure around that if
i say the wrong thing i want to hurt his
feelings one time i said the wrong thing
to my dad and he got mad and hit me who
knows but when it's like oh i like the
way brad pitt does his hair
or he clearly is better in the gym than
you are john right whatever that
whatever that thing is
it takes the pressure off and you're
able to learn about somebody okay
okay so i'm gonna send you
all of them
i don't know why not i'm gonna send you
all of them
uh
oh we'll go through i don't know even
which ones we got in house but i'm gonna
send you the questions for humans cards
for dating and the questions for humans
cards for couples the ones for friends
and here's what i want you to do you can
take those cards and all those cards
help you do is practice safe
conversations like healthy interactions
with other people
okay what i'm saying and so y'all can go
to dinner and then the card asks you
what's the best date you've ever been on
is not me
and suddenly it's like i don't want to
talk about that it's like no i want to
hear what was it it was with tom i hate
tom and now you're in a conversation
right or
would you rather burp
or fart or vomit on a first date right
which one
why right now you're having
conversations about why you think this
versus that and i don't want to be
judged i'm gonna be shamed and this
would be really embarrassing and i
couldn't come back from this one so now
we're having deeper conversations what
we're doing is we're creating a safe
context so that when
she says i really want this color
curtains or you know what i really want
to go to med school
she's got there's relational equity in
the bank
safety that's that sidewalk of your
relationship the foundation of a
relationship is strong and it's it's
concrete and she can stand on it and she
knows it see what i'm saying
yeah
and so i think it's i think it's
practice and if you're not gonna leave
her um and there's not this nagging
thing like i gotta solve this or the
marriage is off then i think that takes
the pressure off of you and now it's
about creating a safe context for her
okay
i do think it's fair to say
um to let her know
my goal with you
is to help create a world where you feel
safe enough to trust me with your
thoughts and hopes and dreams
and she will probably respond with it's
not you you do make me feel safe
and i think the next step is to say i
hope that over time
you will come to love and trust yourself
the way i love and trust you
and if i can ever support you in that
journey and learning to love yourself
and trust yourself as much as i love you
and trust you
whether that's counseling whether it's
marriage counseling whether that's a
book study together whatever that looks
like i'm all in
okay you see what i'm saying it takes
all the pressure off of do we have to do
this or we have to do that or we have to
it takes all that pressure off which i
think is
and it may be she's got a lot of trauma
to unpack it maybe who knows right maybe
who knows what's there um
but come what may she's gonna know
james is gonna be right there with me
he's gonna be right here
and that my friend is beautiful it's
awesome
she's lucky to have you dude that's cool
and good luck let me send me a wedding
photo send it our way
and uh we'll post it on the internets we
probably won't do that it's cool though
i'll just say it i don't know we might
i'll post something right send it to me
i'll post it that'd be great